break down um
the alpha what is the alpha male what is
a beta male for people who hear those
two words and don't necessarily aren't
educated as to what that is man yeah so
alpha beta these are greek letters a b
um and in our society or in our culture
the alpha like alpha
in the the animal kingdom or in humans
is just a more uh
dominant
male a more a leader you know what i'm
saying that's all it is and the betas
are more of the followers you know and i
don't want to get it anything confused
with anybody out there
as saying a alpha is better than a beta
because i'm not i don't think that you
know um actually
i've been talking about this a lot
lately that
like alpha males are becoming less and
less useful in society you know what i
mean
alpha male is useful for himself and
maybe the people closest to them but
what's better for society is better
males and if you look at society our
society is run by beta males regardless
of what people think you know um this
country is a democracy you know i'm
saying with a system of checks and
balances so there's no kings
even the president people when people
really understand
the nature of the government the federal
government the framework of it and all
of the state governments and city
governments
the federal government is is maybe a
little bit more powerful than
the royal parliament [ __ ] in london like
the kings and queens you know what i'm
saying like they're they're just there
for pageantry
listen donald trump when he was in
office he complained all the time about
not being able to get [ __ ] done
because it don't matter you don't you
don't run [ __ ] the presidents don't run
[ __ ]